[Musique]
à partir du début du mois d'août donc le
pass sanitaire s'appliquera dans les
cafés les restaurants les centres
commerciaux ainsi que dans les hôpitaux
les maisons de retraite établissements
médicaux sociaux
je suis dans les avions trains et cars
pour les longs trajets là encore seuls
les vaccinés et les personnes testées
négatives pourront accéder à ce lieu
qu'il soit d'ailleurs clients usagers ou
salade
[Musique]
nous devrons engager dès que les
conditions sanitaires seront réunies la
réforme des retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur oui
parce que nous vivons plus longtemps il
nous faudra travailler plus longtemps et
partir à la retraite plus tard
[Musique]
la réforme de l'assurance chômage sera
pleinement mises en oeuvre dès le 1er
octobre autour d'une volonté simple en
france on doit toujours bien mieux
gagner sa vie en travaillant en restant
chez soi ce qui n'est actuellement pas
toujours le temps
[Musique]